we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in and i'm getting
more and more voicemails like it take a
listen
hello mister cochran love your show his
stuff you might want to consider what
happens the corona virus is so bad when
it comes to election time how will
people get out to vote and vote him out
if nobody show up for the polls i'm
going to think about have a good day
yeah so this is something that people
have been emailing me which is saying
you know we understand that actually
postponing the presidential election is
insanely unlikely but if you have
disproportionately people on the Left
who are taking the quarantine a more
seriously than people on the right if
this doesn't get better by the fall and
you have republicans who increasingly
think Trump is doing a good job dealing
with coronavirus isn't that a situation
ripe for Republicans going out to vote
to reelect Trump and Democrats staying
home partially because they are
following quarantine orders I don't know
the answer but that is a concern that is
a concern the postponement of the
election is unlikely the impact on the
electorate though is something that is
concerning me and I don't have an answer
we'll certainly be thinking about and
talking about this more as we as we
approach November real quick reminder
tomorrow March 25th at 8 p.m. Eastern
Time will be the David Pakman show chess
tournament all viewers and listeners are
welcome regardless of skill level
register on Leach s org for a free
account it's free
and tomorrow night I will be live
streaming my participation in the
tournament and I know there are at least
two some chess players in our audience I
hope we get at least fifty people
playing maybe we'll get more and I
invite you to participate you're sitting
at home board nothing to do participate
in the David Pakman show chess
tournament we've got a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about what
defines a business as essential and much
much more get a membership or pledge on
patreon to get instant access to today's
bonus show people very impressed by the
way with Pat's ping-pong table
a punching bag set up at his home studio
you'll be able to see that again on
today's bonus show I'll speak to you
then